What's up everyone?  Okay, we have already done demand and we've already done supply in other videos and this one.
We are going to bring them together and this is going to help us determine what market equilibrium is.
If you didn't know, Market equilibrium is the condition in which the market clears itself.
It determines the equilibrium price and the equilibrium output or quantity that we will consume as buyers and that producers will sell to the market.
And this is the most efficient quantity that we can possibly have.
So let's jump into this by looking at our table where we bring back our quantity demanded and our quantity supplied along with the different prices.
Give me a second here to go ahead and label this graph with price on the vertical axis, quantity Q on the horizontal axis, I have an upward sloping supply curve.
I have a downward sloping demand curve.
And as I start inputting these prices and quantities, we see that $5 will be where my supply curve starts.
We will see, $25 will be when my demand curve starts.
And then I'm going to have, notice right here, my quantity supplied is equal to my quantity demand at a price of 15.
So that is my market equilibrium price.
So what I'm going to do is just add in some dashes, put in my price $15, put in my quantity of, 20.
And this was 20,000 pizzas.
Okay, this was the pizza market.
Yummy.
All right.  And at this point, we'll call it point E for equilibrium.
We have found the market equilibrium price and quantity.
So our suppliers, our pizza makers, are willing to sell us 20,000 pizzas at a price of $15 US.
As consumers, we are willing to purchase 20,000 pizzas at a Price of $15 each.
Okay, so this is what we ultimately want.
It clears the market.
There is no excess demand, there is no excess supply.
That is, we are not above or below that equilibrium price.
But suppose that we were.
Suppose that we had our other prices of 20 and of 10, dollars.
Okay, so let's add in these, and at these prices, our quantity demand.
Let's start.  Our quantity demand at a price of, $10 is going to be all the way over here and it's going to be 3:30.
And at a quantity, supplied at a price of $10, we're going to have 10.
And at a price of $20, our quantity demanded is going to be 10 and our quantity supplied will be 30.
Okay, so we can see, let's just highlight this.
We can see at a price of $10, we go over, we hit our supply curve first.
We Drop down, our quantity supplied is going to be 10.
If we keep going over, we hit, our demand curve.
And so our quantity Demand will be 30.
If the price had been $10, we would see that our quantity demand would be greater than our quantity supplied.
That is, 30 is definitely greater than 10.
So this actually gives us a shortage, a shortage of 20, because our consumers want to purchase 30,000 pizzas, but our producers only want to sell 10,000 pizzas.
So anytime we are below the market equilibrium price, as we are right here with $10, and as we are right here with $5, we will produce a shortage.
And that is not something that we want.
Now, to clear that shortage, what we have to do is, is increase the price of that good.
And this gets us back to market equilibrium.
Let's switch gears and look at a price above market equilibrium.
So at a price of $20, our quantity demand is going to now be 10, and our quantity supplied is now going to be 30.
So here we see a situation in which our quantity, quantity supplied is greater than our quantity demanded.
This means that the 30 in quantity supplied is greater than the 10 in quantity demanded.
And this gives us a surplus of 20,000 pizzas.
That is, our producers are wanting to sell more pizzas than what our consumers are wanting.
So anytime we are above the market equilibrium price, in this case $15, we will create a shortage.
So, so a price of 20 and a price of 25 creates a surplus in that market.
So in order to get rid of that surplus, our pizza producers are going to have to lower the price of the good.
And that causes us to move along that supply and demand curve back down to the equilibrium price of $15.
And that helps us get back to the equilibrium quantity of 20,000 pizza pizzas.
So we now have an understanding of the supply and demand together.
Let's have a deeper dive into supply and demand conditions.
Let's just rewrite everything here and supply our demand curve.
And we're going to have a hypothetical arbitrary equilibrium price.
We'll call it P0 equilibrium coin quantity.
We'll call it Q0.
And let's suppose that we're going to have an increase in our demand, and we're going to have an increase in our supply.
So our supply curve is going to increase to S1, and our demand curve is going to increase to D1.  Now.
Now, this could have happened for a variety of reasons.
Maybe there's an increase in the number of firms and an increase in the number of consumers.
Ultimately, what do we see?
Our new equilibrium is where the new supply curve and new demand curve intersect one another.
And let's drop down, create Q1.
And we see that we now have a higher price, P1.
But is that always the case?
Is it always the case that we get a higher price and a higher level of output?
No, it's not always the case.
Suppose, instead of my demand curve shifting as far out as it did, or as my supply curve as shifting as far out as it did, let's suppose instead my demand curve only had a small increase as opposed to the very large increase that it did have.
Now look where my new equilibrium is.
My quantity is still greater than my equilibrium quantity, but now my price is lower than my equilibrium price.
So what we can derive from this is that anytime we have an increase in our demand and an increase in our supply, our quantity will always increase, always and forever.
But our price is indeterminate.
We don't know what will happen to price until these demand curves and supply curves ultimately shift.
We get our final equilibrium.
Let's look at another example and give me one second to label everything.
Price and our, quantity, supply curve and our demand curve.
And let's get our equilibrium price, p0.
Equilibrium quantity q0.
And now what we're going to do is we're going to have an increase in demand and a decrease in supply.
So let's just go ahead and draw that decrease in supply so supply shifts back.
Maybe our technology, our, technology decreased, or perhaps we had an increase in taxes, something like that.
And let's have an increase in demand.
So I'm, going to have a real big increase to begin with.
So my demand shifts From D to D1.
So that's a pretty big increase.
And we see our new equilibrium is where S1 meets D1.
And we're going to drop straight down and we're going to have a new equilibrium quantity which is greater than our old equilibrium, and we're going to have a new equilibrium price which is also greater than our old equilibrium price.
Is this always going to be the case?
Is price always going to increase?
And is quantity always going to increase?
And the answer is no, it is not always going to be like that.
So instead of having this, actually, instead of let's have our demand curve stay the same.
But now instead of the supply curve being S1, let's have the supply curve be S2.
Now look where our new equilibrium is.
It's our old equilibrium quantity, but we have a new equilibrium price.
So we can see that price always is increasing.
But quantity could be an increase or, or it could be a decrease, or it could stay the same.
So price will always increase, but quantity is what we call indeterminate.
Now, we don't know what's going to happen to our quantity until it actually happens.
So when we're trying to analyze these market changes, it's very beneficial to go ahead and draw these out and then see what, unfolds.
Another way to do this, and let's start with this basic graph, is when you are making your shift in supply and demand, is to have an exact parallel.
So here's my supply curve, and I'm going to make the same switch in my demand curve, the same change, the same distance from here and here.
I'm going to try to do as best I can while I'm drawing this.
There we go.  A little, little wonky, but we got it in there.
And you'll notice that when we do that, if we go over to our new equilibrium, it's our old price, but our quantity also increased.
So much like what you saw with that previous graph.
Now you can see that my equilibrium quantity will always increase, but my equilibrium price is going to stay the same.
So that's another way to do this, to have parallel shifts to see which curve is going to be the one, or, excuse me, which output or price is going to be the one that changes and which one's going to be indeterminate.
Now, here is a table that sums all of those changes up.
And we did this one.
We did the increase in demand and increase in supply, and we determined that price was indeterminate, whereas quantity always increased.
And we did the increase in demand and we did the decrease in supply.
So in this case, again, we saw that price increase, whereas quantity was indeterminate.
And if you want to, you could also go in and you could do both of these to get these two solutions.
That price is indeterminate and quantity decreases.
When your demand and supply curve both decrease and your demand and supply are decreasing and increasing, and you see that price will always decrease, whereas quantity is indeterminate.
And that is it for this series.
We'll see you in the next one.